The Jungle Book is directed by Jon
Favreau and is the 17th adaptation of
this book we've seen quite a bit of them
I made that number up I don't even know
if that's true but it feels like it is
this is a live-action version it was
entirely done in LA in sets not a single
scene was filmed in an actual jungle all
the animals and locations are CGI
combined with actual sets and that's
kind of insane and I went into this
movie saying wow this is going to be so
bad I was so upset that in film anything
on location it seemed like a giant
cop-out it seemed like a total CGI
crutch and if you know anything about
the jungle book and you know this is
about a little boy named Mowgli who was
raised in the jungle by wolves and is
eventually challenged by sheer Khan the
tiger who rules over this area and has
to try to escape his grasp
by finding his people so it's time for
me to eat some major crow here this
movie was fantastic
I was consistently blown away by this
movie the CG here is absolutely
astounding it's some of the best CG work
I've ever seen the technical prowess it
took to make this movie blew me away I
am so stunned by the look of this film
by the CG work done with the animals the
motion capture work combined with the
onset filming this truly is a
masterpiece of CGI work and I am blown
away by what they were able to
accomplish because I was one of those
people that was like no that's Steven
Dom why are they doing at all with CG CG
sucks we need practical effects
particularly Bagheera the Black Panther
I don't know if in 10 years it'll look
this great but right now today watching
this movie that thing was real and I
cannot believe they were able to do that
because we are actually getting to that
point where sometimes you can actually
you're like is that CG II I grew up with
the 1994 live-action adaptation which
today doesn't hold up as well it's still
kind of fun but you know it's not really
the greatest movie and of course the
original 1967 animated film but I can
tell you that if I was 12 years old
today and I saw this movie for the first
time I would grow up telling everyone
it's a classic it would be my definitive
jungle book movie for the rest of my
life this movie is
well made but on the flipside I am also
a full-grown man now and I think this
will be my definitive version of the
Jungle Book I can't see another
adaptation of the jungle book being this
good even though they are actually
working on one right now which is kind
of nuts and we'll see how that goes in a
couple years is directed by Andy Serkis
so that's interesting but that just goes
to show you that this movie is great for
kids and adults a kid who saw this movie
today would be like this is incredible I
love this I want to buy every action
figure I want to buy all the animals I
want to buy all the plushies but my
theater was also loaded with adults who
seemed to have a great time too so it's
one of those movies that really fits
both demographics let's talk about Bill
Murray as Baloo I mean could they have
made a better choice interest elbow was
very haunting as sheer Khan I mean he
did a fantastic job my issues with the
movie revolve around a few things and
they're fairly minut the newcomer who
plays Mowgli mostly does a very good job
but there are a few times where he has
shifty eyes and you can kind of tell
he's a little unsure what he's acting to
and that's understandable this is his
first movie and to be honest he really
did a great job but there were a few
moments where he could tell he was kind
of acting too nothing trying to struggle
to figure out exactly what he's supposed
to be looking at right now also the
sequence with kava steak played by
Scarlett Johansson
well impressive it felt like a departure
it was very exposition heavy and I
didn't really appreciate it that much
but it wasn't like I looked at that and
said I don't like watching this scene it
just felt like a departure from the rest
of the film and that's really it I loved
Christopher Walken as this giant King
ape my god that was incredible he sings
a song and everything I was in heaven
Christopher Walken singing a song as a
giant monkey can you really get better
than that I don't think you can guys
this movie was great it surprised me on
so many levels Jon Favreau absolutely
pulled it off please direct the
standalone Star Wars movie sir you would
do a great job this is a CGI masterwork
I'm gonna give the jungle book an A - so
guys I just want to say my wife and I
have been floored by the things you guys
have sent me in the PIO box some really
funny stuff somebody sent me the
Dragonball Evolution soundtrack I died
laughing seeing that that was so funny
a Batman V Superman comic was sent to me
as well as a Batman short film which I
hope to see soon Dances with Wolves on
blu-ray which I did not have
a very cool novel about horror films
which I'm excited to read and something
else that just I just can't I someone
sent me harmonies to specialize editions
of Star Wars cooked like with a complete
blu-ray set that they built sir I'll pop
these in yesterday and I just I thank
you name is Curt thank you very much
Curt I am just I don't deserve this man
I really don't deserve this
I don't you guys are the best thank you
so much now today is actually my
birthday and I'm trying to get some work
done as well as do some other stuff this
weekend with my friends and family so
we'll see how that goes but I do want to
review criminal and hopefully barbershop
3 as well because I'm a fan of Ice Cube
and I'm hearing some good things about
that movie so I do want to see it guys
you are the best thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes